c'est la nouveauté et le succès 2019
d'exode games le jeu jurassic world 2
développé par cette start up créée en
2017 est installé à montigny le
bretonneux spécialisée dans l'édition de
jeux de société elle s'est associée à
universal pour créer ce wargame vous
allez créer votre faction développer
votre votre deck de cartes pour
constituer votre armée et faire un
scénario de que ce soit juste faire un
objectif ou alors affronter humains et
dinosaures ou incarner un dinosaure ce
qui est assez rare grâce à jurassic
world exode games a multiplié par trois
son chiffre d'affaires un demi million
d'euros récoltés avec les ventes
les équipes sont passées de 3 à 6
collaborateurs avec notamment l'arrivée
en avril 2019 de marion graphistes
designers ça peut être de la position de
textures ça peut être de la créa
complète en imaginant un visuel de
cartes ça peut être la mise en place
d'éléments
par exemple pour une boîte de jeu ou ce
genre de choses c'est assez varié en
fait n'est par exemple aller chercher de
la texture d'herbe dame brûler des
arbres de la pierre et tout assembler
ces éléments pour créer un environnement
on va dire logique et en même temps
assez esthétique exode games a lancé
aussi exode conception pour les
prototypes et des figurines 3d et exode
studio pour de futurs projets on a
quelques pistes pour développer si
certains jeux en jeux vidéo voir en film
d'animation
donc on essaie de toucher à tout ce qui
est vraiment le métier de l'internement
qui tourne autour du jeu en général ou
de l'animation et on espère que d'ici
cinq ans oui on aura développeurs un
studio de jeux vidéo
objectif pour x games dans les
prochaines années a réalisé 10 à 15 % de
croissance par an